bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire aujourd'hui
nous allons aborder la question du rpt
codage de variables c'est une étape
essentielle de l'analyse 1 puisque halde
en fait au quotidien lorsque l'on fait
une analyse on passe quasiment plus de
temps à faire du rpt codage de variables
qu'à faire l'analyse proprement dit
en tout cas bonsoir à toutes et à tous
nous avions abordé la semaine dernière
la question de la manipulation de
données avec des plats hier on va donc
ce soir continuer sur ce ce jeu de
cessions sur la manipulation de données
avec la recodification de variables
comment est-ce qu'on peut transformer
une variable numérique en différentes
variables catégorielles regrouper des
modalités ensemble tous ces outils là
vont nous être nécessaire pour la suite
et à partir de la semaine prochaine on
va revenir à quelque chose qui est un
petit peu plus en phase avec l'analyse
proprement dite puisque la semaine
prochaine nous aborderons à
la régression logistique et nous aurons
d'ailleurs au début de la session sur la
régression logistique passer du temps à
préparer nos données donc affaire dure
codage de variables en vue de cette
analyse je vous propose de partager mon
écran vous est maintenant habituée à
l'interface de deux aires et de r studio
et nous allons rapidement commencé avec
une première étape qui est renommé une
variable donc pour renommer une variable
c'est quelque chose que nous avons déjà
abordé en fait la semaine dernière
supposons qu'on est un jeu de données et
dans ce jeu de donner une une variable
dont on souhaite changer de nom alors ça
se fait pas de manière simple avec les
fonctions de base dans l'air mais on l'a
vu ça peut se faire très facilement avec
le tailles diverses
alors première chose on va charger un
petit jeu de données qui va nous servir
pour les exemples aujourd'hui ce que je
vous propose c'est de prendre un jeu de
données qui est proposé dans le package
questionneur première chose je vais
choix chargé en mémoire questionnaire
une fois que le package est en mémoire
je peux du coup faire la commande data
hdv 2003 et en faisant ça vous voyez ici
dans l'onglet environnement je dispose
maintenant d'un nouvel objet en mémoire
qui est un tableau de données avec 2000
observations de vin variable si vous
voulez une présentation de hdv 2003 vous
avez ici l'aide associés hdv 2003 donc
en fait il s'agit d'un échantillon de
2000 individus et de vins variable qui
viennent d'une enquête qui s'appelle
histoires de vie qui a été réalisée en
france en 2003 par l'insee et si on
clique sur le lien vous auriez ici une
présentation de l'enquète et des
différentes variables
alors revenons dans les studios nous on
a envie d'avoir une petite idée de
qu'est ce qu'on a dans ce dans ce
fichier de données première possibilité
nous pouvons faire view donc si je fais
view de hdv 2003 le fichier de données
apparaît à l'écran
pour information je vous rappelle que
depuis l'ong l'environnement en haut à
droite
vous avez une petite icône ici qui fait
la même chose qui en fait on voit la
commande view hdv 2003 donc on peut voir
le contenu on a une variable idée qui
est l'identifiant l'âge les individus le
sexe une variable qui s'appelle ni vêtue
et qui est le niveau d'études et
individus un poids statistiques un
niveau de pension le niveau de
qualification le nombre de frères et
soeurs et puis différentes variables
comme l'appartenance ou la croyance
religieuse l'importance du travail dans
la vie
quotidienne et puis est ce que les
individus pratique du hard rock
la lecture de bandes dessinées pratiquer
la pêche et la chasse la cuisine le
bricolage le cinéma ou du sport ainsi
qu'une variable qui est le nombre
d'heures passées devant la télévision
retenez bien ce fichier de données car
il nous resservir à la semaine prochaine
pour la régression de logistique donc
une première manière de voir nos données
1 ça a été violent profite pour vous
rappeler qu'on a deux trois autres
fonctions il ya la fonction look fort
alors blanquefort c'est une fonction qui
est disponible à la fois dans
commissionnaires et dans la belle
éventuellement je vais charger aussi la
belle dans mémoires et si j'applique
look fort à mon fichier hdv 2003 vous
voyez ici apparaître une présentation
des différentes variables donc nous
avons les variables en question la belle
parfois nous l'avons vu il est possible
de donner étiquette de variables c'est
notamment le cas lorsqu on apporte les
données avec havane depuis ça assez
space ace ou stats à lasser un fichier
qui n'a pas d'étiquette de variables
nous pourrions éventuellement les
données manuellement on l'a vu ça nous
sert en statistiques descriptives avec
jean tissé mari vous avez le type de
colonne donc l'âge est une variable
souvenons devant brandt iecex c'est un
facteur nive étude est un facteur on
peut le voir la plupart des variables
catégorielles sont ici codé en tant que
facteur et on reviendra tout à l'heure
sur le fait que l'autre approche qu'on
peut avoir c'est des variables
catégorielles côté sous forme de
vecteurs labellisé une autre fonction
qui intéressante alors je vais aussi
chargé de taille diverse pour qu'on
puisse avoir des plats hier et les
autres package du taille diverse en
mémoire c'est la fonction lims glims
elle vient de dix plats hier et glims si
j'applique le jeu données hdv 2003 ça
nous permet aussi de visualiser de
manière à courcy notre jeu de données
glims 1 nous présente chaque variable
sur une ligne pour une question de
visualisation on n'a le type et des
premières
donc tous ces outils l'un soit notre
disposition pour avoir une meilleure
idée de ce que contient notre fichier de
données pour rappel aussi si je veux
cherche si j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de variables ce qui est
compliqué c'est que si on a 200 300 400
variable ça devient difficile de
retrouver une variable en particulier
mais quand on utilise look fort et si je
mets hdv 2003 je peux aussi donner un
vecteur de recherche je veux chercher
tout ce qui contient ses ol et voyez là
ça va me sortir que la variable
bricolage qui est la 17ème variable du
fichier mais on peut du coup faire des
recherches un peu plus poussé
ceci est en pause et donc revenons à
notre première action sur le jeu de
données qui consiste à renommer une
variable alors renommé une variable on
l'a vu la semaine dernière peut se faire
très facilement avec le verbe wind and
the deep la guerre supposons que la
variable bricole justement je veux la
remplacer par bricolage je vous donne la
commande dont j'ai donc
hdv 2003 par hape wind et bricole
bricolage nouveau nom égal l'ancien nom
là même syntaxe qu'on avait aussi avec
select la différence c'est qu'avec
select je ne j'ai extrait uniquement la
variable bricole conre nomme à la volée
en bricolage avec louis [ __ ] je ne je
me contente juste de faire un renommage
et si je ne sauvegarde pas le résultat
l'information sera perdue je vais donc
copié ma commande
si j'exécute ceci je regarde maintenant
ce que devient hdv 2003 on va faire un
glims d'envoyer j'ai toujours mais 20
colonnes mais ici la maria bricole a été
tout simplement renommée bricolage donc
normalement il devrait pas y avoir un
trou de trop de difficultés sur cette
première partie ce qu'on va aborder
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui
arrive assez fréquemment qui va être de
convertir une variable donc le principe
nous avons une variable qui est d'un
certain type ça peut être un facteur un
nombre entier une variable textuelle et
on a besoin de convertir la variable
d'un type à l'autre alors premier type
de conversion nous voulons convertir une
variable en facteur pour créer un
facteur nous l'avons vu il y a une
fonction générique qui est la fonction
factor donc supposons que je prenne la
variable frères soeurs qui correspond au
nombre de frères et soeurs mais qui est
ici codé de manière numérique joue là
alors je disais describe pour qui est
aussi fournie par cautionnaire pour
avoir un résumé la variable donc si je
vous remonte qu'est ce que contient
frères soeurs frères soeurs c'est donc
une variable dentier qu'yves entre 0,22
et je voudrais le convertir en facteurs
ça peut nous servir dans un salon des
analyses ou justement une variable
numérique on ne peut pas l'utiliser de
manière numérique mais l'utiliser de
manière catégorielles
pour cela je peux faire tout simplement
factor de hdv 2003 dollars frère ça donc
là je fais une transformation de type
facteurs
et si jamais je veux conserver ceux ci
il faut que je pense à l'enregistrer une
possibilité c'est avant tout le monde de
créer une nouvelle variable que je vais
appeler donc
hdv 2003 dollars j'ai appelé fs pour
faire court et donc en faisant ça je
prends hdv 2003 dollars frères soeurs je
le transforme en facteur des jeux le
stock dans une variable f s regardons à
quoi ressemble un variable
f s j'ai donc un facteur et on voit que
ce facteur à 19 niveau qui corresponde à
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 et ainsi de suite
donc l'idée c'est quand on prend une
variable numérique et qu'on l'a
convertie en facteur en fait chacune des
valeurs de la variable numérique va être
converti en un niveau du facteur là je
vous ai montré ici dans cette syntaxe la
hdmi 2003 dollars effet ce flash
d'assignation factor
hdv 2003 frères et soeurs c'est une
syntaxe classique à en langage r
j'aurais pu aussi vous montrer à une
syntaxe on va dire plus à la deep la
guerre comme on l'a vu la semaine
dernière donc avec dix plats hier quand
on veut transformer une variable on a
recours à mme ute et j'aurais pu faire
donc
hdv 2003 mon par hape newton et je crée
une variable effet ce qui est égal à
factor deux frères soeurs si je veut
sauvegarder le résultat je pense à
écrire au début donc là s'être deuxième
ligne lgv 2003 est égal à hdv 2003 sur
lequel j'applique un newton et je crée
une variable effet ce qui est égal à
facteur deux frères soeurs c'est là la
même syntaxe la syntaxe dit plat hier ce
qu'on retient c'est que andy plat hier
donc on écrit la formule dans le mieux
tête et j'ai pas besoin de faire de
répétition de hdv 2003 dollars frères
point soeur puisque ici frères point
soeur comme il est à l'intérieur deux
minutes et va être compris comme une
variable de hdv 2003 alors on peut aussi
assez facilement transformer une
variable textuel en facteur toujours
avec factor alors on va prendre un
exemple je vais prendre je vais créer un
objet x qui contient le texte à baa1
c'est d'accord je vous fais une
description de ce qu'est x donc encore
une fois je reprends la fonction des
scribes qui est fourni dans
questionnaire puisque ça permet d'avoir
un petit résumé un peu lisible donc
c'est un vecteur textuelle et je peux
créer un objet que je vais appeler y qui
va être facteur de x et donc il y
maintenant c'est un facteur qui a trois
niveaux possibles
ab c'est donc la transformation entre
une variable textuel un facteur se fait
très facilement avec factor alors factor
a d'autres options pour les usages un
peu plus avancé puisque quand on glisse
factor vous avez la possibilité avec le
paramètre levels de dire quels sont les
niveaux attendus et dans quel ordre
j'aurais pu dire par exemple y égale
facteur 2 x et l'hiver égale les valeurs
possibles sont c b
à quand je fais ça j'obtiens bien
facteurs sauf que j'ai dit quel serait
le niveau possible
et du coup l'ordre des niveaux
correspond à ce que j'ai donné j'aurais
pu aussi dire qu'il ya que le niveau des
taux autorisés et là j'aurai un facteur
qui contient les mêmes contenus mais
avec un niveau d qui est également
possible où j'aurais pu dire que à n'est
pas un des niveaux autorisés
et donc dans ce cas là à la création du
facteur a aurait été remplacé en arena
puisque c'est pas dans les niveaux
autorisés
alors au quotidien ces usages plus avant
cette factor vous verrez qu'on va
pouvoir passer outre et que souvent ce
qui est plus simple c'est éventuellement
de créer un facteur avec facteurs de
manière simple on verra après comment on
peut facilement recoder changer les
étiquettes et ainsi de suite
maintenant qu'on a un facteur on peut
aussi très facilement le reconvertir
vers une variable textuel ouvert une
variable ouvert une variable numérique
si je reprends y alors je vais prendre
peut-être une ancienne version de y
donc je reviens ici je vous présente y y
et donc un facteur qui contient ab a
assez et les niveaux autorisés du
facteur sont dans l'ordre cba des jeux
peut convertir mon facteur en variable
textuelles pour ça je vais avoir recours
à la fonction à ce point caractère donc
deux bases dans air vous trouverez pas
mal de fonctions qui sont aux points
quelque chose et qui en général sont des
fonctions qui permettent de convertir
d'un certain type à un autre donc si je
fais aspir'acteurs de y
ce que je veux obtenir c'est un vecteur
textuel qui contient les valeurs ab a
assez je peux aussi convertir mon
facteur en nombres entiers et si je fais
has integer de y
j'obtiens 3 2 3 3 1
pour comprendre la conversion d'un
facteur en nous en entier ce qu'il faut
retenir en fait c'est que là le nombre
entier représente la énième position du
niveau si vous reprenez grecque le
premier niveau cessez donc les valeurs
c'est ont été transformés en un
le deuxième niveau c b et donc du coup
les b ont été transformés en 2a et le
troisième niveau les uns ont été
transformés en 3 et dès le quatrième
niveau les démonter rencontre mais en
quatre or il n'ya pas de dés dans ce
vecteur y
on peut aussi de 2,2 de la même manière
si on veut avoir non pas un vecteur par
exemple je vous fais un autre vecteur on
peut convertir aussi du numérique vers
les entier avec à ce point numérique
et puis à ce pur integer 6 x est égale à
1,4 dont je vous fais un disque rock 2 x
x était un nombre ici entier supposons
que je fais y qu'ils soient has
numérique 2x et je vous fais un disque
live de y
on obtient simplement la même chose sauf
que c'est toujours les valeurs 1 2 3 4
mais cette fois-ci codé en numérique
quand on convertit des entier a aidé
nombre
à quand on convertit des entiers vers du
numérique c'est à dire des nombres avec
virtuelles envoyées il n'y a pas de
souci c'est un petit peu différent dans
l'autre sens supposons que x soit un
vecteur qui va contenir un 2.2 et 4.5
donc ça c'est un vecteur numérique
ah pardon je fais 85 et supposons que je
fasse pas
integer 2x je vais convertir mais je
vais perdre du coup ce qui se passe
après décimales louis hémon 2.2 a été
convertie au chiffre de jeu perd une
information donc sans surprise lorsqu on
convertit des nombres avec des si mal en
entier on va perdre l'information qui
est la partie après décimales n'y a pas
vraiment de
surprise à avoir ici donc il faut juste
réfléchir un tout petit peu alors une
des questions qui est posée c'est est ce
qu'il ya une différence entre facteurs
et entre factor et à ce facteur
alors à ce facteur permet aussi la
conversion donc si je prends x il est
ici si je fais facteur de x j'obtiens
ceux ci et si je fais as factor 2x on
obtient la même chose pour le coup en
fait à ce facteur de x factor sont
équivalents la différence est que à ce
facteur permet juste de convertir en
facteur avec les options par défaut on
peut rien personnalisé alors que facteur
permettrait de pouvoir personnaliser les
options les verts si on voulait avoir un
ordre particulier où la belle ce qui
permet de faire dur que d'argent qu'en
fait factor offre beaucoup plus
d'options que à ce point facteurs mais à
ce point facteurs fonctionne comme
facteur
on verra un peu plus tard un dans
d'autres exemples et on verra c'est que
quand on convertit une variable textuel
avec factor sans option par défaut par
défaut du cours ont les niveaux du
facteur sont toujours dans l'ordre
alphabétique et on a besoin de passer
par d'autres astuces pour mettre dans
d'autres zones mais on va voir un peu
plus tard qu'on a des petits outils à
disposition qui permettent de facilement
changer l'ordre en fait des niveaux d'un
facteur autre question sur le tchat
pourquoi certaines variables son talent
de type double cela at il un intérêt
alors une variable double c'est la même
chose qu'une variable numérique de
manière sous-jacente pour comprendre en
fait entre les deux c'est que les
variables numériques sont codés sur 2
octets ou est une histoire comme ça et
donc du coup elles sont considérées
comme double ou avec double précision ce
qui ce qui est important pour vous au
quotidien vous ai pas besoin de retenir
ces aspects très poussée au niveau
informatique c'est retenez retenez
double c'est la même chose que numérique
donc une variable de type double c'est
une variable qui peut avoir des chiffres
après la virgule
alors qu'une variable entière ça ne peut
être que 1 2 3 4 5
donc dans un certain nombre de cas on a
besoin d'avoir la précision après
décimales si vous avez une variable qui
est la taille des individus exprimée en
mètre vous allez avoir besoin d'avoir le
chiffres après la virgule
il ya plein de situations on a besoin de
chiffres après la virgule retenez
surtout double c'est la même chose que
numérique
alors avant d'aborder il ya un cas de
conversion qui est quand même un petit
peu compliqué c'est la question des
variables labellisé donc conversion des
vecteurs labellisés
si vous vous souvenez on l'a abordée
dans les chapitres sur les teams de
variables et notamment au moment de
l'import lorsqu'on a pas des données qui
viennent à deux sas tata ou spss et
qu'on fait l'importation avec heaven on
a des variables qui sont les catégories
ne sont pas coder en tant que facteur
mais sont souvent codée avec un coach
chiffre 1 2 3 ou 4 auquel on associe une
étiquette et les étiquettes sont pas se
suivent pas forcément vous pouvez avoir
une variable qui va être codé 0 non un
oui 9 ne sais pas de plus il peut y
avoir des variables qui n'ont pas
forcément qu'ils n'ont pas forcément des
étiquettes pour toute leur valeur
et en fait ça c'est un système qu'on
retrouve dans stats à oudon espèces et
donc à vonn importe en variable
labellisés
j'avais déjà abordé à l'époque le petit
schéma que vous avez ici sous les yeux
qui est le fait que lorsque l'on va
faire des analyses ou lorsque l'on va
produire des graphiques on aura besoin
que les variables catégorielles soit
codé en tant que facteur est donc dans
un processus d' enquête et analyse des
enquêtes
on a deux approches possibles soit vous
importez vos données avec espèce s ous
tata
vous convertissez toutes vos variable
apportées soit en facteur pour les
variables catégorielles selon vous les
repasser en variable purement numérique
et ensuite nous travaillons uniquement
avec des facteurs ou des variables
numérique c'est-à-dire des formats
classiques dans aer pour toutes les
opérations de nettoyage de reco d'âge de
préparation et vous réalisez vos
analyses
c'est une première approche possible ou
dans quel cas ce qu'on va appeler des
vecteurs labellisé n'est qu'un format
temporaire au moment de l'apport dans
d'autres cas de figure la situation peut
être un petit peu différente parce que
on va apporter dans air des données on
va vouloir faire décodage des créations
de variables ou de la recodification
mais en gardant ce type de codage
c'est-à-dire un codage numérique avec
des étiquettes associé ce qu'on peut
parfaitement faire on l'a vu on a le
package la belge qui fournit toutes les
fonctions pour cela avec cette variable
et set value la belle hausse qui vont
permettre de donner des étiquettes de
valeur et donc dans ce cas là ça arrive
notamment dans des projets ou à la fin
de cette opération de préparation donné
on va repartir sur l'export de données
d'un côté pour avoir un fichier propre
qu'on veut archivés au long cours il
puis seulement après on va avoir une
partie analyse dans ces gros projet là
on aura donc intérêt à faire un apport
de donner à faire toute une partie
nettoyage reco d'âge transformation à
des données en restant sur des données
labellisés pour produire un fichier de
données le plus propre possible puis à
l'étape de l'analyse dans une partie à
part de votre de votre projet faire à la
moment où on a besoin une conversion des
variables catégorielles en facteurs et
des variables continue en variable
numérique
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que les
vecteurs labellisé ne sont pas adaptés
pour l'analyse dans aer et donc il
faudra faire une conversion à un moment
donné ou un autre
alors on va revenir ici et on va surtout
chargée de mémoire le package la bndes
puisque le package label death et le
package qui va nous permettre de
manipuler de manière fine des variables
labellisés je vous propose de charger un
deuxième jeu de données en mémoire c'est
un jeu de données que nous réutilisons
d'ailleurs dans une prochaine séance sur
l'analyse de survie et qui est aussi
fournie par cautionnaire donc aux
actionnaires est déjà en mémoire on est
bon et on va faire date à fécondité
quand vous faites data fécondité vous
charger le jeu de données fécondité qui
est composé de trois fichiers le fichier
enfants le fichier femmes et de fichiers
ménages alors s'il s'agit de données qui
ressemble à ce qu'on appelle les
enquêtes démographiques et de santé
ceux qui travaillent dans les pays en
développement connaissent bien ces
enquêtes là ce sont des grandes enquêtes
faites à intervalles réguliers donc on
est des données qui sont similaires dans
le concept c'est une enquête ménages
nous avons donc un premier fichier
ménage avec des informations sur chaque
ménage puis un fichier femme qui est un
fichier avec le questionnaire qui a été
passé à chaque femme du ménage et le
fichier enfants c'est que dans le
questionnaire tes femmes on leur demande
des informations sur chacun des enfants
qu'elles ont eu donc leur histoire
génésique et là on a un fichier qui
contient ces informations là on viendra
sur à d'autres moments dans les analyses
comment ongles quand on a des données
qui sont à différents niveaux et qui
sont hiérarchisées mais regardons juste
pour voir comment se situe le fichier
femmes
on va faire deux choses déjà je vous
faire un look fort de femmes donc cette
fois-ci look for nous renvoie la
position des variables au nom des
variables pour que nous avons une
variabilité famille déménage poids des
d'entretien voyez les variables ont une
étiquette ici non ce fichier de données
nous plaisons un label car une étiquette
de variables n'oubliez pas que les
étiquettes de variable peut s'appliquer
à n'importe quel type de variables ça
peut être un facteur ça peut être une
date ça peut être un vecteur labellisés
et on a certaines variables comme
l'identifiant qui sont stockés sous
forme d bf c'est à dire doble retenait
numérique on a des vecteurs de date
on reverra ça lorsqu'on abordera la
gestion des dates et puis vous avez de
la catégorie comme le milieu de
résidence ou la région de résidence et
ce ne sont pas des facteurs elle son
coude et sous la forme d bl plus la
belle
c'est pour dire ce sont des données
d'ibol donc des données numériques qui
sont labellisés et là en fait ce qu'on
nous indique c'est que le code 1 est
utilisé pour que des urbains et 2 est
utilisé pour coder rural si je fais un
glimpse de femmes
voyez les variables catégorielles comme
le milieu de résidence ce qu'elles
contiennent ce sont des nombres
non c'est pas urbain et rural ce qui est
contenu c'est un ou deux simplement on a
indiqué qu' une étiquette pour nous dire
à quoi elle correspond si je fais view
de femmes
et que je vais voir ces fameuses données
comme région milieu voyez c'est bien les
chiffres qui sont stockés donc
retenez bien la différence entre un
facteur est une variable habits lisez
c'est que on a simplement mis des
étiquettes on peut regarder de manière
un peu plus fine avec des scribes si je
fais describe de femmes région on
m'indique que c'est une encore une forme
dit que ces labels des ballons c'est une
variable numérique labellisés on a les
différentes étiquettes pointe et crée
donc c'est une variable qui a quatre
étiquettes et qui a l'étiquette nord
associé à un l'étiquette est associé à
2d qui a eu des soucis à 3 et
l'étiquette ouest associé à quatre pour
convertir donc on est dans un cas
typique un d'une variable labellisés qui
est une variable catégorielles nous
avons quatre valeurs uniques dans ce
fichier qui sont que des nombres et
chacune de ces valeurs dans le fichier à
une étiquette associés donc c'est
vraiment le cas le plus simple c'est
typiquement une variable qui est
catégorielle qui en terme d' analyses
seraient à serait à traiter comme une
variable comme un facteur et on va plus
coup pouvoir la convertir en facteur
grâce à la fonction ce n'est pas à ce
point factor mais la fonction tout
underscore factor fournis par la belle
alors la fonction porte un nom différent
tout simplement parce que les données
labellisés sont pas du bazert et donc du
coup on rentre pas dans l'est il ya eu
un choix d'un hommage un petit peu
différent mais si je fais tout facteur
de femmes de la région
alors je tiens ce si c'est pas très
lisibles car il ya 2000 observation mais
je vais enchaîner ces ricains describe
donc si je fais tout facteur de femmes
région on a tout simplement convertis
le vecteur labellisé en un facteur et de
manière très simple et là ça se passe
très bien parce que toutes les valeurs
de femmes région 1 2 3 4
on étiquette la question c'est qu'est ce
qui se serait passé si jamais et appelé
l'étiquette pour tous alors on va
modifier ça je vais reprendre du coup
femmes le partir de femmes et je vais
faire cette vague value labs et je vais
modifier du coup les étiquettes
non juste retiré une étiquette donc
c'est cette danse et we move
valliot c'est ça we move value label ce
que je suis un peu la syntaxe attendez
on va regarder donc le mot value label
ce permet de supprimer
permet de supprimer certaines valeurs un
des étiquettes donc là ce que je veux
faire je pars de femmes weemove value la
benz est la variable région je veux
retirer l'étiquette associé à 4 d'accord
donc cette syntaxe weemove value label
je me permets de retirer à de retirer
l'étiquette qui associé à la valeur 4
pour la variable région et je vais
sauvegarder ce résultat si je fais un
disque live de femmes région vous verrez
maintenant que j'ai plus que trois
étiquettes l'étiquette nord associé à un
l'étiquette est associé à deux et
l'étiquette sud
associé à 3 si je fais thiou factor de
femmes de la région
mais je vais faire un disque rock dans
la foulée pour montrer qu est-ce qu on
obtient dans ce cas là et bien par
défaut ce que faire tout facteur c'est
que si jamais il ya une étiquette noix
des valeurs qui n'ont pas d'étiquette on
prendra directement la valeur en tant
que tel pour créer le facteur l'idée
c'est qu'on ne perd pas d'information
alors tout facteur à différentes options
et en particulier vous avez une option
les house qui vous dit qu'est ce que
vous voulez comme niveau par défaut
d'accord on va vous créez des niveaux à
partir des étiquettes mais vous pouvez
aussi passer comme option lives égale
value zh
c'est un petit peu subtil mais ça veut
dire que dans ce cas là on va faire un
facteur mais les niveaux vous
correspondant valeurs qui étaient sous
jacentes
et puis vous pouvez avoir aussi l'option
préfixe qui vous permet en fait alors
c'est plus quand on travaille pour soi -
dans un graphique qu'on présenterait à
l'extérieur mais ça permet en fait de
faire des niveaux qui correspondent aux
codes chiffres avec l'étiquette ce qui
fait qu'on perd pas l'information
d'accord et donc dans ce cas là mon
facteur je crée toujours un facteur mais
avec un or de s3 sud 4 4 vous avez aussi
d'autres options qui peuvent être
intéressants notamment nos labels tout
est né vous pouvez considérer que si
jamais il n'y a pas d'étiquette associés
il faut pas en faire un facteur et il
faut le convertir en valeurs manquantes
et si je fais ça non la berd tout y est
vous avez voyez les quatre qui n'avaient
pas d'étiquette ont été convertis ici en
valeurs manquantes et vous avez un petit
peu d'options supplémentaires
je veux aussi vous montrer le cas opposé
ce qu'est ce qui se passe quand il ya
une équipe
une étiquette qui n'a pas de valeur
observée donc je vais reprendre femme
est ce qu'on va faire femmes had value
la baisse donc vous verrez vous avez
vraiment valu le label c'est pour
retirer des étiquettes de valeur adval
yuv là bas c'est pour ajouter des
étiquettes de valeur aux étiquettes déjà
existantes et vous avez set value la
baisse ou la sai on remplace la
définition complète donc là avec al
value label ce donc pour la variable
région et je vais dire que je vais
rajouter l'étiquette alors les
étiquettes c'est toujours sous la forme
non valeur et je vais dire ah je vais te
créer une région centre qui est égal à 5
je vous refais une description du coût
de la variable femmes région donc a valu
la base ici m'aura permis de rajouter
une étiquette intitulé centre associé la
valeur 5
d'accord vous voyez ici j'ai une
variable numérique qui a du coup quatre
étiquette nord associé un est associé à
deux sud associé à trois centres
association bien les étiquettes peuvent
être associés à n'importe quelle valeur
et vous ai pas besoin de ça se suivent
on a une très très grande souplesse avec
les étiquettes si je convertis
femme région on va faire de ce prime
je vais rajouter l'option leval égale
plus fixed alors petite astuce ou si
vous voyez que parfois vous avez des
options qui sont souvent d'une liste on
vous dit la berle value ce préfixe est
quelque chose qui marche quasiment dans
toutes les fonctions
vous n'êtes pas obligé de mettre le nom
entier je peux mettre simplement paix
dans ces cas là on va regarder qu'il est
la première valeur qui corresponde paya
pas de il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté et je
tiens même chose que si j'avais vu plus
fixed donc là tout factory jean le cam
qui n'avaient pas d'étiquette a été
convertie dans une valve dans une valeur
donnée pour pas qu'on perde
sauf si on avait dit avant que leno la
barre tout est mia égale trop mais
l'étiquette 5 qui n'a pas de valeur
observée ya pas de centre dans le jeu de
données et bien envoyé
et c'est là où vous avez une option
additionnelle qui s'appelle drop and
used la balle ce qui permet de dire que
des étiquettes qui ne serait pas observé
dans jeux de données sont tirées du jeu
de données donc en fait on a plein de
deux petites subtilités c'est important
de bien savoir qu'est ce que vous voulez
a derrière donc première chose quand on
a un vecteur labellisés quand on a un
facteur labellisés on a cette
possibilité de le convertir en facteur
avec tous factor retenez aussi que la
fonction tout facteur peut être appliqué
directement sur tout un jeu de données
je vais créer je vais l'appeler ff je
vais prendre le jeu de données femme et
je lui applique tout factor donc tout
factor c'est pâques à 2 2
de azinhaga ainsi de suite mais tous
factor a été codé de telle manière à ce
qu'on puisse l'appliquer sur tout un jeu
donnait donc sur un tableau et dans ce
cas là en fait tous factor ne touchera
pas aux variables qui ne sont pas
labellisés mais convertir à toutes les
variables labellisé en facteur donc ça
c'est une manière d'aller très vite et
de convertir une seule fois toutes les
variables labellisé en facteur je vous
montre à quoi ressemble
ff donc look faut de ff voyez gp2
variable labellisé mais variable qui
était non labellisés sont restés des
barres numériques les wable date n'ont
pas été échangés c'est juste que les
variables labellisés ont été convertis
en facteur en une fois toutes les
options de tout facteur de tous facteurs
peuvent s'impliquer
j'aurais pu faire tout facteur avec
l'option leuwers et galp et pourpre et
fixed et à ce moment là jouent le monde
ce qu'on aurait obtenu avec un look fort
donc dans ce cas là on aurait confirmé
en facteur en ayant appliqué le préfixe
âge systématiquement donc ça se
permettent de faire des choses à la
volée le problème c'est que c'est pas
forcément toujours pertinent d'appliquer
un tout factor en masse sur tout un jeu
de données
parce que et là ça va dépendre de
l'origine de vos données
il arrive assez fréquemment qu'on ait
aussi des étiquettes sur des variables
qui doivent bien être conçue comme
numérique par exemple
regardons la variable âge donc ici dans
mon jeu
j'ai donc une variable h d'accord avec
des femmes qui sont âgés entre 14 et 49
ans et c'est une variable numérique
il arrive parfois que sur d'autres jeux
de données on est des classes d'âge
beaucoup plus large par exemple qu'ils
aillent de 18 jusqu'à 90 ans
et puis en fait les gens qui auraient
plus de 99 ans on les codes aussi 99 et
du coup dans le jeu de données qu'on
récupère il ya une étiquette qui nous
dit bah 99 veut dire 99 ans et plus donc
on peut avoir des variables numériques
qui sont bien considérés comme numérique
mais qui ont malgré tout une étiquette
je vous fais l'exemple si je fais femmes
et on va convertir cela donc je vais
dire à agde value la berce à âge et je
vais acheter un label qui va être 99 ou
plus oui là je comme j'ai des espaces je
mets mon label entre entre guillemets et
que j'applique à la valeur 99 et ça il
faut que je sauvegarde dans femmes
pardon je reprends je prends femmes
j'ajoute une étiquette à la variable âge
et je sauvegarde le résultat dans femmes
je vous fais un disque reip de femmes
âge
donc là ce qu'on a c'est une variable
qui du coup devient une variable
labellisé avec une seule étiquette
appliqué à 99 est en fête avec un âge
qui est sous forme numérique supposons
je refasse ma commande de tout à l'heure
qui consistait à appliquer tout factor
sont l'objet femme et que je règle a
sauvegardé sa dans un objet fff et que
je regarde ce que j'obtiens avec look
fort de ff est bien la variable âge
voyez aura aussi été transformé en
facteur alors qu'on n'aurait pas dû le
faire donc c'est pour ça qu'à un moment
donné on peut pas de manière
systématique transformer toutes les
variables de type label death en facteur
parce que ça dépend au cas par cas
alors comment faire pour retransformer
ma variable agents une simple variable
numérique
on a deux options la première serait de
supprimer tous les étiquettes associé à
la variable âge avec la fonction qu'on a
déjà vu tout à l'heure qui est remove
value
la berce donc serez été femme weemove
value labase sur la variable âge et
appartements il ya plus d'étiquette ça
redevient une variable non labellisés on
a aussi une autre possibilité il sait
l'utiliser en classe pour vous montrer
un class retire la classe sur un objet
et sur un vecteur labellisé ça nous
redonne sa valeur pure a donc si je fais
une classe de femmes de la rage et je
vous fais un disque rock dessus
ça devient simplement une variable
numérique donc pour le convertir
j'aurais pu faire tout simplement femmes
mignot tate âge égal en classe 2 e âge
alors ce qu'il faut bien retenir dans
tout ça c'est qu'il faut toujours être
très vigilant lorsqu'on fait de la
conversion de manière large sans savoir
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
faire une fonction qui peut être utile
et c'est la fonction ahnlab out qui vous
est présentée ici on fait un peu la berd
l'idée c'est si toutes les valeurs
observées ont une étiquette sa converti
en facteurs sinon ça reconverti en
numérique et la bad peuvent être
appliqués sur un jeu de données en
entier donc supposons que ff ce soit
maintenant femme un label death look
fort de ff ce qui se passe ici c'est que
la variable âge redevient numérique
parce que il ya une étiquette que pour
la valeur 99 et donc il ya d'autres
valeurs observées qui n'avaient pas
d'étiquette la vibe région pareil est
devenu numérique parce que souvenez vous
tout à l'heure je vais retirer
l'étiquette et on avait plus cette
concordance là par contre pour toutes
les autres variables qui était bien
documenté ça a transformé en facteur ce
qui est à retenir c'est que cette étape
de conversion des variables labellisé en
facteur ou en vecteur un numérique
c'est quelque chose d'important et vous
devez savoir ce que vous faites de
manière générale n'oubliez jamais quand
vous avez un jeu de données
on va prendre le temps
de bien savoir comment comment le
traiter et proprement
on va aborder maintenant quelques
techniques un peu plus pratique ça
arrive souvent un conte et le besoin
maintenant de convertir une variable
numérique en classe on a vu qu'on
n'avait facteurs mais on a besoin de
faire des groupes d'âge alors l'exemple
typique c'est la variable âge on est
tous amenés on a l'âge si je reviens sur
femme alors je vais recharger on va
revenir sur hdv 2003 je vous remontre
hdv 2003 j'ai donc une variable âge je
vais vous faire une description rapide
de la variable âge donc c'est la valeur
numérique pour notre analyse pour ça
pourrait être pour faire un graphique ça
peut être pour la manière dont on va
traiter l'âge dans un modèle notamment
dans une régression logistique
on peut avoir besoin de découper la
variable e âge ont plusieurs classes
d'âge on pourrait avoir sur des classes
quinquennal tâche par exemple avec 15 19
ans les 20 24 ans les 25 29 ans les
30-34 ans quelque chose qu'on retrouve
assez régulièrement dans certaines
enquêtes alors des groupes quinquennaux
il faut avoir quand même beaucoup de
monde ou découpées dans d'autres groupes
c'est de manière générale comment
fait-on pour découper une variable
numérique en différentes classes et pour
ça il ya une fonction essentielle c'est
la fonction qui est la difficulté avec
la fonction quote je vous avouerai c'est
que je me souviens jamais très bien d'un
syntaxe et il ya une bonne raison à cela
c'est que on
n'a pas besoin car l' excellent package
questionnaire nous propose un add in
dédiée à la conversion d'une variable
numérique en classe léa dinin vous vous
en souvenez on en avait déjà abordé
quelques uns
et si vous allez dans le menu à dean et
que vous cherchez questionnaire et
beaucoup d'additions mon pc donc pour ça
il faut que le package kouchner soit
installé sur votre pc pas forcément
qu'ils soient chargés en mémoire et
coactionnaire à un indigne qui s'appelle
numérique branche dividing j'avais
cliquez dessus et ça me propose une
interface interactive qui va me
permettre de pouvoir créer une nouvelle
variable
alors je vous choisissez d'abord le
fichier de données moi je veux partir de
hdv 2003 je veux recoder la variable h
et ensuite vous devez indiquer est ce
que vous voulez remplacer votre variable
existantes ou créer une nouvelle
variable
je vais l'appeler groupe h à ce stade là
quoi je tenais rpt ne fait rien un
cautionnaire ici va proposer un outil
pour générer le code et là vous êtes
libre de d'expérimenter il sait encore
rien passé on encore rien changer en bas
je vais cliquez sur le deuxième onglet
qui est découpage en classe alors pour
nous aider à faire notre choix quoi
tonnerre vous affiche directement ici un
petit histogramme de la distribution de
la variable où je vois que l'âge varie
entre un peu moins de 20 ans jusqu'à à
peu près 100 ans
vous avez ici le nombre d'observations
vous avez le résumé pas de valeurs
manquantes minimum de 18 maximum de 97
avec une médiane à 48 et vous avez
plusieurs manières de pouvoir découper
votre
variable en classe vous avez la
technique dite et coire whif autrement
dit vous indiquez un nombre d'intervalle
donc je voudrais quatre groupes et ça va
chercher automatiquement où sont les
coupures pour permettre d'avoir des
groupes de même amplitude
donc ça vous prend le minimum le maximum
et ça vous dit vite pour avoir la même
amplitude
vous avez des techniques comme les quand
il si je veux ça va divisés en groupes
de même taille
donc là par exemple avec la méthode
compte-il dont d'intervalle 4 savent a
découpé en quatre groupes
avec le même nombre d'observations vous
en avez différents algorithmes qui sont
à votre disposition mais parfois on aura
tout simplement recours à une méthode
manuelle ou vous indiquer où est ce que
l'on veut couper si on réfléchit d'un
point de vue sociologique on a des
grands groupes d'âge
souvent on fait une distinction entre
eux donc manuel
je vais couper à 25 parce qu'on a les
jeunes qui ont moins de 25 ans puis
coupé on va dire à 60 ans fin de la vie
active et on aurait du coup les jeunes
moins de 25 ans les 25 60 ans qui serait
la période actuelle et les 60 ans et
plus qui formera dans un groupe où
peut-être que je distinguerai les 25-40
ans les 40 60 et puis les
60 81 ans pour avoir les personnes très
âgées
mais voyez si je prends 91 ans ça sera
peut-être pas beaucoup de monde donc je
peux éventuellement mettre 75
l'intérêt ici c'est qu'on peut explorer
et on voit visuellement le rendu ce qui
est surtout intéressant c'est que si je
clique maintenant sur code et résultat
vous avez le résultat obtenu
là on se rend compte qu'on a un groupe
de 25 à 40
avec 522 personnes 40 60 avec 793
personnes soit 175 avec 368 personnes et
j'ai 317 manquons ce 317 manquants ça
vient du fait qu'on n'a pas les valeurs
extrêmes et donc la salle et des coupes
de 25 à 40 mais ça me fait pas un groupe
les moins de 25 ans on peut cliquer ici
a ajouté les valeurs extrêmes si
nécessaire je vais sur que des résultats
on a bien du coup les en fait à rajouter
dans les coupures 18 et 97
ce qu'on voit c'est clair on a un groupe
qui va de 18 à 24 ans puis un groupe de
25 à 30 alors de 18 ans inclus à 25 ans
exclut donc ça fait du 18 24 et de 25 a
inclus à 40 on exclut d'intervalle ils
peuvent être ouverts ou fermés à droite
et vous avez ici une option vous pouvez
cocher qui va changer ce résultat là là
en cochant ça ferait un groupe qui
rêvent de 18 est lui à 25 ans inclus de
exclu à 40 explique et ainsi de suite je
vais décoché et puis vous avez aussi une
option qui est là si vous regardez bien
j'ai une valeur non content parce que
mon dernier intègre un intervalle il
n'inclut pas la toute dernière valeur en
cliquant sur un clou à la valeur extrême
ça l'a bien réintégrer la toute dernière
valeur de l'échantillon ici et je n'ai
plus de mots qu'ont donc l'intérêt ces
deux d'avoir
c'est de bien vérifier ce qu'on fait à
gauche on vérifie le résultat en bas à
droite les a bougés nerfs ici le code
qui va permettre de créer votre nouvelle
variable quand c'est fait vous cliquez
sur donne alors ça n'a pas exécuter le
code ça vous a copié ici le code
nécessaire pour faire votre codage vous
pouvez soit le copier et le mettre dans
la console pour l'exécuter tout de suite
ou sinon le copier pour le mettre dans
votre script si vous êtes en train de
travailler sur un script vous voyez les
différentes options
donc ça prend une une
[Musique]
votre variable include the white dj
l'aps et c'est ce qui va jouer sur ces
les options qu'on a coché ebrex qui dit
ou faire les coupures
donc ya pas besoin de retenir toute la
syntaxe ce qui est important à retenir
surtout c'est qu'on a le adin on peut
jongler avec pour voir comment le créer
et on récupère un code qui est
personnalisable
alors est-ce que le découpage en classe
d'âge est possible s'il y a des nerfs
ans anna variable âge
oui tout à fait on peut faire un
découpage en classe d'âge s'il y a des
nerfs oussama variable âge simplement
les haines à resteront dna
on verra par la suite qu'on peut
transformer ces n 1 en une modalité ce
que produit la fonction cut c'est un
facteur je vous montre avec un dess
cribe la variable que nous venons créé
est ce que l'on obtient c'est un facteur
dont les modalités sont 18 25 avec
crochet parenthèse 25 40 40 60 60 75
on va voir par la suite que si on veut
faire un rapport un peu propres de jolis
graphiques on va pas dire 18-25 avec des
crochets peut-être qu'on va renommer sa
en 18-24 et donc ça va nous permettre
d'aborder tout de suite une deuxième
possibilité c'est recoder un facteur
pour ça on va pouvoir disposer d'un
deuxième à dean qui nous est proposée
par mark toner il ya plusieurs syntaxe
possible pour god est un facteur il ya
plusieurs fonctions qui sont là quand on
veut faire des choses un peu poussée que
les facteurs il ya un paquet de la
conect et package for cats qui propose
pas mal d'options
là on va voir ce qu'il est possible de
faire directement avec les add in de
quoi ionnaires qui vont gérer la grande
partie au quotidien donc dans l'est a
dit je vais rechercher kwaito na et vous
avez ici
les vans bricodeal comme tout à l'heure
on nous demande de prendre d'indiquer
notre tableau de données
la variable que l'on veut recoder on va
voir là pour le coup à prendre l'exemple
du niveau d'études est ce que on veut
garder la même variable
on me dit attention existe déjà donc
dans ce cas là le lard code écraserait
la varenne existantes ou est ce que on
veut créer une nouvelle variable par
exemple que je vais appeler niveau
d'études et vous allez ensuite cliquer
sur codage donc là vous voyez les
modalités qui sont existantes
aujourd'hui nous avons n'a jamais fait
d'études a arrêté ses études avant la
dernière année d'études primaires
premier cycle deuxième cycle
enseignement technique ou professeurs
coup renseignements techniques ou
professionnels l'ont enseignement
supérieur y compris technique ou
supérieur alors ça fait un petit peu
beaucoup de modalités on vous en plus
qu'il ya du mans quand moi je vous
propose qu'on fasse une recrue d'un peu
plus simple on va avoir un niveau
primaire
un niveau secondaire
un niveau supérieur un pardon ça c'est
technique un niveau supérieur et puis
les manquants qui sont manquants
j'aimerais en faire une catégorie en soi
donc plutôt que de les garder comme
manquants si je faisais un modèle eh ben
c'est gens là serait retirée du modèle
je vais faire une catégorie niveau
manquants ou manquant tout simplement et
je clique sur code et résultat et vous
voyez déjà ici le premier élément c'est
qu'est ce que c'est devenu donc c'est
assez facile hein ce que j'ai renommée
de la même manière va être fusionnée
dont var concon combiné du coup ses
modalités la ensemble donc j'ai une
variable primaire avec n'a jamais fait
d'études arrêté ses études dernière
année d'études primaires un niveau
secondaire un niveau technique
un supérieur et les manquants ici
devienne une nouvelle modalité on a
juste à remplir qu'est-ce qu'on avait
qu'est-ce qu'on veut avoir ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que vous avez plusieurs
types de syntaxe je vais vous montrer
déjà la syntaxe de base qui est car
l'acteur comme flight son caractère
c'est là une syntaxe en base air et à la
fin on va dire voilà on veut une
variable numérique et si je vais sur que
des résultats voilà ce qu'on obtient
donc en syntaxe airs classiques on va
prendre notre variable niveau études
pour ne pas avoir de soucis on va la
transformer en une variable textuel
ensuite on va modifier chacune des
modalités donc en fait je prends la
variable niveau études avec hdv 2003
dollars niveau études entre crochets
dans le cas où hdv 2003 nive études &
gas légale n'a jamais fait d'études
je remplace par primaire ont fait ça
tout du long
de plus on rajoute une ligne
si c'est mon camp je sais devient
manquants et enfin je retransmets je te
re transforme les choses en un facteur
il ya une autre syntaxe qui nous est
proposée qui est une syntaxe qui repose
sur la fonction f city week end donc
dans le teil diverses un je vous avais
déjà évoqué le paquet de forecast for 4
fournit beaucoup de fonctions pour
manipuler les facteurs on en verra au
fur et à mesure toutes les fonctions de
fort 4 commence par excepté comme
facteur pour faire pour facilement son
souvenir et on va voir du coup la
syntaxe
dans ce cas là ce qui est un petit peu
différent le principe c'est que donc on
prend hdv 2003 neuf études qu'on
applique à ft rico et ft recode c'est
nouvelle valeur égale anciennes valeurs
c'est une syntaxe à la deep lier donc
simplement avec la fonction fct oui qu
on va créer toutes les toutes les
fonctions et puis enfin on appelle une
deuxième fonction qui s'appelle fct
explicite ena et f c'est explicite est
naze est une fonction qui permet de
rendre les valeurs manquantes une
catégorie en tant que tel je vais faire
donne hélas on récupère le code si je
veut exécuter tout ça il faut que je
prenne ce code et que je les exécute
ici dans la console alors ce cop aussi
se présenter un petit peu différemment
je vais vous le copier la dans un script
r pour vous montrer qu'on peut aussi
présenter sa un tout petit peu
différemment en termes de syntaxe alors
déjà alors on peut utiliser ta but tab
et shift tabac pour faire avancer ou
reculer du code sur votre clavier
c'est un tout petit peu plus lisible
comme ça mais ce que je vais faire je
vais utiliser le pape
donc du coup je vais dire que nive
études je vais repartir de nive étude à
laquelle je lui appliquer fct rico on va
déplacer
ceux ci et on va dire que là dessus on
applique c'est toujours la même variable
explicité n'en manquons donc ce que vous
avez là excusez moi ce que vous avez là
est tout à fait qu'yves allant aux codes
qu'on a fait c'est juste qu'il est
présenté un petit peu différemment
profite du pai pour le mettre dans une
quelque chose qui est peut-être un peu
plus facile à lire et à suivre je prends
novetude lui appliquer cette et rico
depuis je lui a piqué fct explicite anna
je vous dis ça et je je je je vous
montre assez différentes manières de
présenter ces syntec juste parce que
c'est une sorte d'exercice à avoir au
bout d'un moment pour savoir comment
jongler de l'un à l'autre arrivait s'y
retrouver au début ça peut être un peu
compliqué après on arrive à comprendre
la logique et à basculer facilement
d'une un type de syntaxe à un autre type
de syntaxe
une fois qu'on a là on a vu comment on
pouvait facilement changer les
étiquettes un facteur on peut en
profiter pour pour alors je suis pesons
maintenant en fait que je me changeais
que un élément je voudrais je voudrais
en basset technique park teknik sage
professionnel je changeais une étiquette
du facteur on peut toujours passer par
le même magazine
donc ça va être livrée en cause
oui coding alors je reprends à d'in
libro de kooning donc c'est dans mon
fichier hd vie 2003 je prends la
variable que je ne crée ni l'étude
je veux pas en créer une nouvelle donc
ça va juste un remplacement est la seule
chose que je veux faire c'est remplacer
supérieur par supérieur t on pas cette
technique par technique slash
professionnels donc là je fais juste une
production légère un qui va être juste
modifié un des niveaux et vous vous
voyez ici le code qui est produit en
fait on passe toujours pareil c'est eric
aude
ancienne valeur égale nouvelle valeur
par don égal ancienne valeur
donc on veut que techniques
professionnelles correspondra technique
la seule chose c'est que si on dit rien
pour les autres modalités
elle reste tout simplement identique
donc si on veut modifier la on n'a même
pas faire de regroupement on peut passer
tout simplement par par cette fonction
on peut aussi avoir besoin de changer
l'ordre des modalités d'un facteur on y
reviendra notamment la semaine prochaine
parce que dans le cas d'une régression
logistique c'est même essentiel de
pouvoir définir l'ordre des modalités
d'un facteur notamment parce que la
moitié de référence est la première
modalités du facteur voilà on a un
deuxième à ding qui nous est proposé qui
s'appelle lievens ordering toujours par
quest ix honneur donc on va prendre
hdv 2003 reprenons notre
yves études je garde le même nom c'est
pour te remplacer ma variable est gérée
ordonné cette fois ci pour changer
l'ordre des modalités vous avez juste à
glisser déposer et on peut du coup
facilement changer l'ordre des modalités
attendu vous cliquez sur code et
résultat et vous avez ici le résultat
attendu
alors ça utilise la fonction excepté
aubenas d'alain boublil côté la fcpe de
laval fait toujours partie de for cats
ce qui se passe c'est que on ne modifie
pas les modalités on indique juste les
modalités dans quel ordre on veut les
avoir si vous voulez faire de manière
manuelle
on peut aussi le faire de manière
annuelle avec les critères ils veulent
donc je vous fais un des scribes de hdv
2003 ni vu ni vin ni vos études pour que
vous voyez la variable avant recod donc
là c'est primaire secondaire technique
supérieure mon camp je vais la
transformer donc
hdv 2003 niveau études c'est égal à hdv
2003 dollars niveau études j'appelle mon
pays et je vais appeler appliquée
accepté oui les vallons avec et cetera
laval je vais dire que ce que je veux en
premier c'est long quand puis je veux la
catégorie technique et je m'arrête là je
vous montre ce qu'on obtient
j'obtiens manquant technique et si j'ai
pas dit le reste eh ben fc termine la
valve a tout simplement utilisé les
dernières modalités dans l'ordre
inchangé et mais avec maileva l'on peut
très facilement
changer toutes les ordres des modalités
si vous voulez faire quelque chose sur
un facteur mais vous savez pas quelle
fonction utilisée n'hésitez pas à
profiter de leur studio et de sa du fait
qu'on a de l'auto complétion si je tape
fct underscore je vois apparaître toutes
les fonctions qu'ils commencent par fct
underscore vous voyez il ya était à 9,6
explicite et na in france in sync et je
peux regarder à chaque fois ce que
l'afld ce que ça fait c'était collapse
permet de fusionner différents niveaux
dans des groupes qu'on a défini par
avance fc tech en quoi c'est pour
croiser deux facteurs
on peut voir par le nom commençait à
voir ni de ce que ça peut faire
et si on ne sait pas trop où on peut
toujours regarder l'aide d'une fonction
par exemple fc tales of love to give a
fuck you think you ou 20 alors comme ça
c'est pas très très clairement on va
regarder un des exemples qui nous est
fourni il a je prends l'exemple du
fichier dette donc là j'ai un hic c'est
donc un vecteur où on a les valeurs a b
c d e f g h i j avec 40 personnes dans
le groupe à 10 ans groupe b 5 dans le
groupe c et 27 ans groupe d et les
autres groupes sont peu présents si je
fais x fc tel homme n 3 et là vous avez
un tas pour voir le résultat
et bien ça groupe ensemble et c'était
l'homme va regrouper en somme dans une
catégorie autres tous
eh ben ça avec un gars les trois
premiers les trois plus grands groupes
voyez à b et d
les groupes les plus présents sont
conservés et tout le reste est mis dans
over fct l'umps pop 0,10 donc 0.10 ça
veut dire 10% et bien sa garde ensemble
tout les niveaux qui ont au moins 10
pour qu'ils sont moins présents à 10%
dans l'échantillon et sava groupe et le
reste est ainsi tu est donc en fait on a
plein de petites options et de choses
pratique quand on veut retransformer la
ftt l'umps et ses variations qui propose
du coût des fonctions pour facilement
permettre de regrouper les modalités peu
présente en catégorie ensemble selon
différents critères et keith où sont
détaillées ici
ce que je sais c'est que si jamais je ne
travaille sur les facteurs j'ai donc
flockhart et package de basse je peux
chercher les fonctions qu'ils commencent
par fct avec éventuellement l'auto
complétion
et puis l'autre outil intéressant c'est
d'utiliser du kulo cicchitto deux foires
caps quand vous allez dans l aps
vous avez le menu cheats et vous ai
cliqué sur bronze cheats pour voir tous
les cheats disponible est allé sur le
site web de r studio car tous sont pas
directement dans le menu
ici on va chercher et vous en avait un
qui porte sur le package le bridge ce
alors il va être tout simplement quelque
part si je mets factor donc là vous en
avez une pour travailler avec les
facteurs avec le paquet de fond kraats
je vais cliquez sur download enregistrer
le fichier et on va l'ouvrir
et donc du coup vous avez un résumé de
toutes les fonctions qui existent et qui
sont proposés ajouter ou retirer des
niveaux combiné des facteurs entre eux
inspecté un facteur changer l'ordre des
différents niveaux
ça peut être au hasard sa patrie vous
voyez vous avez une petite un petit
exemple et donc pareil là vous allez
retrouver un certain nombre d'options
qui sont disponibles il n'y a pas besoin
de les connaître tous par coeur là on
avait vraiment les éléments de base dure
codage avec les deux add in de 2 kw
actionnaires qui vont vous servir au
quotidien
mais sachez du cook ont assez des
options supplémentaires qui nous sont
qui nous sont possibles
je vous propose maintenant de voir
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour des
variables un petit peu plus compliqué et
supposons qu'on veuille faire des
groupes à partir à partir d'éléments un
peu plus complexe et pour ça nous allons
aborder deux fonctions intéressantes qui
sont if i rise et lorsque je les ai
différence et kane et malheureusement je
n'ai pas dansé pour le court sous les
yeux
alors ces deux fonctions sont pas
présentés dans reco d'âge de variables à
mais sont présentés dans dans dix plats
hier non pardon excusez moi je dis une
bêtise
elles sont bien présentés dans le
chapitre sur leur cottage de variables
le principe de f1 horse et phrase est
une fonction qui va nous permettre de
choisir deux modes de calcul suivant que
quelque chose est vrai ou faux supposons
que je veux faire une variable tout
simple qui serait une variable jeunes
vieux donc dans la gv et 2003 une
variable âge je voudrais une variable
qui vaut jeunes c'est les personnes au
moins de 40 ans
et moins jeunes c'est les personnes en
plus de 40 ans une première possibilité
donc j'ai créé une variable que je vais
appeler groupe
je vous montre la variable en question a
converti lisez donc on va aborder
différents dons qu'ils fassent nous
permet de créer de faire de calcul
différent suivant qu'une chose est vrai
qu'une chose est fausse je vais prendre
hdv 2003 et je vais faire une syntaxe la
mi août est alors je vais vous mettre ça
dans une dans un fichier ici de scripts
pour avoir quelque chose de plus lisible
pour vous donc j'ai acheté je pars de
hdv 2003 et je vais faire 1 minute et à
la toute fin je vais souffrir des
résultats dont j'oublie pas de m ag.b
2003 assignation du résultat je veux
donc créé une nouvelle variable qui
s'appelle groupe et je vais simplement
écrire if hell ans avec le thunder score
vous avez aussi faire sa tâche et qui
est historique il faut ajouter au score
et une version un petit peu même lieu un
petit peu améliorée fournis par dix
plats hier je vais mettre en condition
là c'est âge inférieur à 40 si oui ça
vaut jeunes sino savent au moins jeunes
et je vais exécuter cette commande
voyons voir ce que donne la variable
qu'on a créé donc htv 2003 dollars
groupe descours arabe
j'ai une variable textuel avec deux
groupes jeunes et moins jeunes d'accord
qui aura été créée donc ça c'est ça peut
être tout simplement différence permet
de créer éventuellement quelque chose de
groupe on peut avoir des cas de figure
on a des variables un peu plus complexe
et on va faire un calcul différent ça
arrive parfois pour certains indicateurs
alors regardons la variable sexe qu'on a
dans l'échantillon hommes et femmes avec
une majuscule
je pourrais faire un je vais l'appeler
un score juste pour montrer un exemple
seïf el ma condition c'est sexe égal si
c'est un homme ça sera l'âge au carré -
33 alors que si c'est une femme donc ans
quand on est dans le cadre différent ça
serait âge au cube - 225
je vous fais un calcul ici qu'à pas de
sens particulier mais ce qui est à
retenir c'est que avec mon iphone je
sais pas forcément une valeur texte que
je vais passer c'est un calcul si oui un
calcul sinon donc if he ans permet
de fait un art au codage valeur si oui
valeur sinon et ça peut être une formule
de calcul
par contre quand on veut faire des
choses un peu plus compliqué supposons
que je veut regrouper
je veux faire les hommes jeunes les
hommes âgées et les femmes
eh bien il faudrait faire plusieurs
conditions et là ça commence à
compliquer et donc pour aller plus loin
que le ive arr
c'est à dire aller vers quelque chose on
aurait plusieurs tests les uns au-dessus
des autres
on va aller sur 15 wen alors je vais
faire une nouvelle variable que je vais
appeler groupe 2 là je vais appeler
kewell et comme ça va me prendre un peu
de place je vais mettre sur plusieurs
lignes
les idées de keynes brienz et première
condition alors c'est une syntaxe un peu
atypique puisque ça va être ça va
s'écrire sous la forme de condition
tienne tu vas là par exemple
première condition sexe égale hommes et
âge inférieur à 40
sealed alors ce t-il dit il va nous
servir souvent noir c'est le symbole que
l'on obtient avec la touche alt gr 2
sous windows c'est le petit c'est
l'accent qu'on retrouve aussi en
espagnol et donc ça que sega l'homme et
agen faire un quart en je vais dire ça
ça sera hommes jeunes à la fin de ma
ligne je vais taper virgule sexe égales
aux hommes
et âge supérieur à 70 ça sera le groupe
des hommes âgés et troisième condition
sexe égale femmes et là je vais dire que
ça vaudra du coup femmes
que se passe-t-il si je fais ça je vous
montre le résultat donc
hdv 2003 dollars groupe 2 des scribes
j'obtiens une variable qui alors qu'yves
of fame hommage et hommes jeunes et j'ai
485 manquants je vous explique comment
ça se passe pour chaque observation on
regarde la première ligne est ce que
c'est que c'est égal à homme et âge est
inférieure à 40 si oui j'ai un groupe
qui est homme jeune et puis je regarde
si ce n'est pas remplie je regarde la
deuxième ligne puis si jamais je ne
rentre pas dans les deux premiers et je
regarde la troisième ligne est là en un
cas particulier ce sont un homme si
jeune homme de 60 ans et ne remplit pas
la première condition au regard naïf
suivante il ne remplit pas la deuxième
condition on regarde la ligne suivante
il remplit pas la troisième condition on
regarde l'année suivante il n'y en a pas
donc on obtient du mans caen
solution pour dire mais tout le reste on
fait une catégorie autres ça va être de
rajouter à la toute fin je hais je vais
faire autre je fais ce qu au delà et je
vous montre le résultat
cette fois ci mais 85 manquants sont
devenus des autres pour comprendre et
gars est toujours vérifier c'est une
condition qui marche dans tous les cas
vous me direz mais pourquoi c'est pas
les 2000 personnes qui sont du coup dans
le groupe
autre et bien c'est et les 485 de tout à
l'heure car les conditions sont regardés
les unes après les autres et on regarde
la condition suivante que si les
conditions précédentes n'ont pas été
remplies
si j'ai un homme de 25 ans on regarde la
première condition
la première condition est remplie on
affecte la valeur hommes jeunes et on ne
regarde pas ce qui se passe ensuite
autrement dit la dernière ligne n'était
valve et que pour les individus qu'ils
ne remplissent pas les trois premières
conditions à savoir des hommes entre 40
et 70 ans dont quinze wayne est vraiment
intéressant pour faire des des
codifications un peu plus complexe là je
voulais fait sous la forme de la
condition valeur conditions valeur
conditions valeur conditions valeur mais
vous pourriez aussi faire des choses
avec conditions formule de calcul
conditions formule de calcul conditions
formule de calcul
et comme je me doute que kezman est un
petit peu plus compliquées qu'elles sont
du coup vos questions alors une première
question la création d'une variable à
partir de deux plusieurs variables à sa
taille diverse
vous avez ici la réponse en fait on va
utiliser une série de conditions pour
arriver tout simplement à
allez créer une autre élément c'est j'ai
l'habitude d'aller regarder les
nouvelles variables créée à la fin du
tableau de données pour vérifier sur
quelles observations leur codage et bien
réalisé est ce une mauvaise pratique pas
du tout j'ai envie de dire que c'est une
très bonne pratique de vérifier que
leurs cadets âge c'est bien fait une
première manière de vérifier déjà c'est
de faire un discours à bout un tableau
de données pour voir l'ensemble qui est
là quand on passe par les add in con
l'envi tout à l'heure qui sont fournies
par par questionnaire vous voyez qui
vous fait le tableau croisé variables
d'avant variable d'après pour des
raisons de sécurité et puis vous avez
effectivement le fait de passer par un
view donc si on fait view de hdv 2003
vous avez directement à la toute fin les
nouvelles variables créé la difficulté
une des questions vous poser ses yat il
une possibilité d'aller rapidement la
fin du tableau de donner quand on a
beaucoup de deux colonnes alors pas
forcément de manière très simple mais ce
que je pourrais vous conseillez c'est de
ne pas faire un view surtout le tableau
donné mais que sur les variables
d'intérêt je m'explique si je veux
vérifier marc codification ce que j'ai
envie de voir l'ag utiliser sexe et âge
pour créer groupe 2 sauf que groupe ii
et à la toute fin du tableau 5 ch sont
au début
une manière de faire c'est de faire hdv
2003 de ne sélectionner que les
variables qui m'intéresse donc ce qui
m'intéresse pour ma part c'est sexe âge
et groupe 2 les variables qui m'ont
servi à construire et celle qui est
construite et j'applique le view sur ce
tableau ce qui fait que je vois à
l'écran directement les trois variables
en question côte à côte
et là je peux voir ligne alice j'ai bien
fait mais recodification ce qui est
certain en tout cas c'est que vérifier
serco diffic à sion au fur et à mesure
qu'on les faits est toujours une bonne
pratique et c'est même nécessaire de
bien vérifier sarkozy fication
de la même manière là aujourd'hui on a
vu un serveur de fonction et je vous ai
fait le code de reco d'âge directement
dans la console
ça c'est une mauvaise pratique une bonne
pratique en fait c'est de faire un
script et au début du script on charge
les données importées on écrit le code
et à la fin du script on sauvegarde les
données recoder pourquoi parce que si
jamais plus tard vous vous rendez compte
qu'il ya un endroit où j'ai fait une
erreur dans votre colis fication vous
avez juste à corriger votre script et
vous pourrez relancer tout depuis le
début
alors pour revenir sur la question de
jambon beurre sur le fait de recréer une
valeur partir de deux ou plusieurs
variables dans la syntaxe tailles
diverses
on peut avoir moyen quand on a deux
variables
deux types factor envie de regarder
toutes les combinaisons de ces deux
variables
si je refais describe hdv 2003 j'ai du
coup maintenant une variable jeunes
et puis j'ai une variable sexe je
voudrais faire directement quatre
groupes une possibilité c'est d'utiliser
interactions alors j'ai fait un variable
âge sexe essayez donc égale à
interactions de la variable à gros et de
la variable sexe je ré exécute tout ça
voyons voir la variable que j'obtiens
hdv 2003 dollars sexe j'obtiens une
nouvelle variable avec quatre groupes
jeune homme - jeune homme jeune femme et
moins jeunes femmes dont clavary la
fonction interactions qui une fonction
de base dans r c'est une fonction qui va
produire l'interaction de deux facteurs
là il se trouve que le groupe est une
valeur textuel a été transformée à la
volée en facteur mes interactions va
produire à nos facteurs qui correspond à
toutes les combinaisons de toutes les
modalités du première du premier fichier
vers toutes les modalités du second
fichier avec et du coup ça vous rajoute
un point entre les deux donc ça permet
de faire très rapidement la combinaison
de deux variables
alors une question de catherine galets
et que fait-on quand on a des données
manquantes avec 15 wayne pour qu'elle
reste manquantes
si jamais tout simplement à condition de
ne pas remplir si supposons je revienne
sur cet exemple là et je veux que si
jamais sexe ou âgées manquant je gare du
mans corps je pourrais dire il n a sex
who is n
à âge alors on envoie manquants
là ce que je fais je fais une
vérification manuelle je regarde est ce
que la vague sexe ou la variable âgées
manquants auquel cas je renvoie mon camp
sinon je renvoie autre que madonna ni
fait que tout est égal autres une autre
possibilité
c'est d'ici de mettre la bonne condition
ça voudrait dire que six ex égale hommes
et âge supérieur ou égal à 40 et âge
inférieur ou égal à 70 alors je renvoie
autres dans ce cas là supposons que la
quelqu'un on in variable une valeurs
manquantes à sexe si c'est que ces
manques en premières conditions sont
remplies
deuxième condition ne remplit troisième
condition ne remplit quatrième condition
non remplies on n'a pas pu résoudre
il n'y a pas de aucune condition valable
ça va générer une valeur manquantes
supposons que nous ayons maintenant une
femme dont l'âge est manquant si on
avait une femme mais que lavables âge
étaient manquants pour cette femme la
première condition ne remplit deuxième
condition est remplie troisième
condition s'est rempli donc on aura
femmes
et maintenant un homme dont l'âge est
manquant première condition de remplir
deuxième condition de remplir troisième
condition non remplies quatrième
condition nous remplit donc on va
générer du hainaut en fait à chaque fois
que vous avez des valeurs manquantes ça
à vous de bien penser quand vous faites
vos recodification quand est ce que le
mans caen doit générer du mans quand
c'est vraiment dans la manière dont on
va écrire nos conditions là je vais
écrire tous les cas de figure de manière
logique incessants c'est ce qu'on pétait
à 100% pour les deux variables sont bien
renseignés et donc du coup s'il ya des
conditions qui n'arrive pas à se remplir
ça va générer du coup un manque on alors
ensuite il y avait une question sur
peut-on mettre la modalité autres à la
dernière position
alors je suppose que c'était
probablement là que fcf c'était l'homme
quoi qu'il en soit une fois que vous
avez un facteur c'est vous qui
choisissez la position du facteur il
suffit de repasser par le made in
libéraux ordering et vous pourrez tout à
fait rejoint dire quelle est la position
du facteur qui vous qui vous intéresse
alors il nous reste plus beaucoup de
temps et déjà 18h30 et je pense que vous
êtes que vous êtes fatigué je vous
propose qu'on s'arrête là pour ce soir à
moins qu'ils aient toutes dernières
questions
on a ici les éléments de base en termes
de reconnaître variable retenez on à la
conversion d'un type à l'autre et
surtout si vous travaillez de labelliser
soyez vigilants à quel moment vous
voulez convertir si vous n'êtes pas
donné labellisés il y aura du coup moins
de problèmes les pour coder les
variables on peut s'en sortir et faire
quasiment la plupart de nos activités
juste avec les trois à digne de co
actionnaire je voulais rappel vous avez
numérique winch de weining pour
convertir une variable numérique en fac
tu en facteur ix en différentes casses
les vacheries calling pour coder les
modalités les vélos sorte de ring pour
changer l'ordre et après s'ils ont des
choses un peu plus poussé n'oubliez pas
d'en gagner et shit ou de regarder
directement for cats sur ce qui peut
proposer de manière générale n'hésitez
pas non plus dans certains cas allez
voir sur quoi tonnerre ou sur
l'analyseur ou d'aller voir sur internet
vous trouvez probablement des petites
astuces pour recoder
il peut y avoir des choses plus
complexes à mettre en oeuvre mais ces
choses que complexe à mettre en oeuvre
on les verra directement par la suite
sur des exemples concrets lorsqu'on
abordera différentes analyses
la semaine prochaine on va aborder la
régression logistique et forcément on va
commencer par recoller à préparer nos
données pour la régression logistique
quand on abordera l'analyse de survie
vous verrez des choses un peu plus
poussé avec des variables textuelle de
date puisque l'année de survie et une
analyse biographiques et au fur et à
mesure des exemples en fait je vous
propose qu'on aborde les prochaines
questions de codification au fur et à
mesure pour né des exemples concrets de
nalyse dans tous les cas n'oubliez pas
que dans quelques semaines nous aurons
de nouveau une gestion de type et fak
une foire aux questions et donc du coup
n'hésitez pas à mettre en oeuvre la ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui sur vos propres
données et on vous pousse si vous avez
des questions qui émergent on pourra les
aborder avec des exemples concrets à
l'occasion de la session faq foire aux
questions
pour le moment je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée
bon courage dans votre apprentissage de
r surtout n'hésitez pas à mettre en
oeuvre par la suite sur vos propres
données c'est le meilleur moyen
d'apprendre
n'hésitez pas à revoir la vidéo en mode
ralenti et a très vite à la semaine
prochaine au revoir